I have a very strange video for you I'm
not going to spend a ton of time on this
but Donald Trump issued another one of
these visibly confused statements in
which he defends the January 6th rioters
and there are so many hypocrisies and
double standards here let me play the
video first and of course Trump says oh
the country's going communist and a lot
of this normal stuff let's look at the
video then we'll talk about it
in my
in my very very unfairly and we're going
to get to the bottom of it and you know
what I've said I take it very seriously
I have never seen anything like it at
all levels it's the weaponization of the
Department of Justice and we can't let
this happen in our country because our
country is going not socialist they've
skipped over that they've skipped over
socialism our country is going
Communists now Trump doesn't even know
what either of those terms mean and he
says this often at rallies we went by
yeah I used to say socialists but now I
say communist he has no clue what he's
talking about just remember that what
happens and we can't let it happen we
have to stop it so I want to thank
everybody for working so hard I know how
hard you're working to get Justice for
people that are imprisoned right now and
people that are being tormented can't
let it happen we're going to stop it
we're going to win thank you listen
Trump is talking what you you know you
might be wondering what are they what
are they what people are in prison what
do you mean or people are being people
are being uh tortured
Trump is talking about pre-trial
detention now we have to take this piece
by piece because this is of such
critical importance first of all
I'm not on the side of the criminals
period okay as I always say if BLM does
something and it's illegal
if antifa does something and it's
illegal there's you know if at a protest
of whatever crimes whether or not they
are actually part of those groups
because as we know Mass Gatherings also
bring out Bad actors and are are you
really in BLM or not I don't care guys
if you commit crimes you should be
prosecuted and if you're convicted you
should be penalized I say it about
Hunter Biden I don't care about
political orientation and it's the same
thing with the writers now you look at
the capital breach cases you can find
the list okay on the website of the of
United States attorney's office for the
District of Columbia justice.gov
you can read through this
and you'll see the names of these folks
and where they were arrested and what
they're accused of and you see that
there are a number of different crimes
many of these are serious crimes
our opinions matter less
about the individuals then about what is
our approach when we say we are for Law
and Order
when the Trump people say we are for Law
and Order part of it means here is the
law
and we have to allow the process to take
place now they are bringing up
issues about the rioters that they never
cared about before I'll give you an
example pre-trial detention
I've talked about pre-trial detention on
this program for more than a decade and
pre-trial detention is when you are not
given bail or you can't afford bail you
stay in jail until the time of your
trial and I've talked about how this is
um often used as a way
uh or it becomes a way in which
individuals are less able to build a
defense they're not able to afford
lawyers because they can't keep working
while they are uh better maybe a better
lawyer they're not because they're not
able to work while they are in pre-trial
detention Etc I've been talking about it
for a really long time and I've talked
about how pre-trial detention
disproportionately affects uh poor
people minorities it's we've talked
about it
these Republicans never cared about it
now they do because they see hey this
pre-trial detention stuff is really
unfair they're keeping all the rioters
in jail until their trials yes we've
been talking about it for a very long
time it's not being used as a political
weapon against these people this is the
system and we've been complaining about
it for a long time
so there's the hypocrisy and there's the
depravity of saying we finally found
people we believe are worthy of our
defense and they pick the Trump rioters
which is absolutely crazy how dare the
doj go after people
many of whom are on video committing
crimes that's unfair it's a political
Witch Hunt it's Bonkers and we are
seeing the sentences roll in and that's
a very good thing